Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth. We're going to
get candid with it. This uh this vision
that Kase saw. The video that's going
viral that got 20 million views in two
days. It's it I just couldn't let this
go because I can't believe how many
Christians are just eating it up.
They're just saying this was a vision
from God. Hands down. a thousand%
even some of the biggest name YouTubers
in the Christian world were just like,
"Yes, goosebumps, chills from the mouth
of babes."
And even going as far as saying, "If you
don't believe that this is a true vision
from God, you must be one of those
people that think that God is just, you
know, he doesn't do anything anymore. He
doesn't do signs and wonders and
miracles, and you don't believe in the
power of God, basically. That is so
unfair. That's so not true. And you
wouldn't believe some of the comments
I've actually received from
uh just from the things that I've been
questioning about this comments I've
gotten from people that are telling me
I'm literally evil for questioning. I I
am evil for questioning a vision.
Okay? For one, I'm not questioning the
word of God. You know, it's not like I'm
questioning the Bible. I'm questioning a
vision, a supposed vision. So, do you
just believe every person that walks up
to you and said, "Oh, I got a word from
the Lord. Uh, you're supposed to marry
me." U, no. Right? You're not just going
to fall for that. Well, it's got to be
real. He was crying. I mean, come on.
The things that we buy into simply based
on our emotions is is incredible. And
Satan knows the power of manipulation.
He knows how easy it is to manipulate
our mo our emotions. And it happens
through music. It happens through good
movies, whatever it is. You know, that's
how propaganda works so well because
they can feed you something that's not
even morally right with the right kind
of music, the right kind of setting, the
right kind of romantic feel to it, and
suddenly you're you're eating that up.
You're accepting it. They're loving it
because it's it's emotional
manipulation. And so I'm not saying at
all that this kid did anything wrong.
This kid got in a accident, went to the
hospital, and he was not in control over
what happened. So I called this from the
moment I saw it. I did not get emotional
watching this. There was not a a shred
in me that thought that this was real,
that he was actually having a certain
kind of spiritual encounter. But I knew
that this was a drug talking. And we're
going to see it straight from his
mother's mouth because this video came
out
today or yesterday. And so this is his
mother giving a little update on the
scenario. Now, listen what she says.
Oh, I was pressing the wrong button. All
right, here we go.
>> The feeling in that room was so
powerful. You just felt the presence of
God. Even though that there was so much
chaos going in the room, there was
probably like five other children that
were getting woken up from anesthesia.
And
>> so, she literally just told you that
this is a room full of kids getting
woken up from anesthesia. So, she's
admitting from her own mouth that her
child, Kasein, is coming out of
anesthesia. She actually goes into more
detail about how he broke his arm. It
was very traumatic. They had to put his
bones back in the socket, so they had to
put him on some intense anesthesia. Here
she's going to say that
>> we were at the skate park and he had
fallen and broken his arm pretty bad.
And it was very traumatic cuz I he was
my He's my first child to break a bone.
They needed to reset his bone. So they
had to put him under anesthesia in order
to do that. And just that and just him
going under an anesthesia was scary to
me.
>> Yeah. Cuz anesthesia is a drug. And so I
I asked Google, I already know the
answer. I've been looking into this for
a while that ketamine is a very common
uh anesthesia used. But I said, if a
child broke his arm and needed to have
his bone reset and put under anesthesia
to do so, what anesthesia might the
nurses administer? And here it's it's
given this whole breakdown, but the the
website that pops up here from National
Institute NIH.gov gov says ketamine
sedation for let's seek ketamine
sedation for the
reduction of ch children children's
fractures in the emergency department.
So ketamine is used for children as an
anesthesia. So I'm not just making
something up. This is research. I mean
this is all we have to do. We have to
stop buying into our emotions. start
thinking logically, rationally, and most
of all biblically. When things these
signs and wonders and visions,
you know, Jesus said an adulterous
nation looks for a sign. He's saying no
sign will be given. And he's saying, you
know, those who did not see and believe
are more blessed and all these things.
And yet, we always are looking for some
kind of prophetic vision or miracle or
this and that. And that's exactly what
Satan's going to give. Satan is the one
coming with the lying signs and wonders.
Think about these terminology. This is
all in Revelation, all the prophecies of
the end. Lying signs and wonders,
uh, miracleworking demons.
It's always the deception,
the miracles, the quote unquote
miracles, the the signs and wonders
that's going to deceive the entire
world. And if it were possible, the
elect. And that word elect is a very
small number. It's not just well I
believe in Jesus. I'm part of the elect.
No, it doesn't matter if you just
believe in Jesus. You have to worship
him in spirit and in truth. And what is
the truth? The truth is that you can't
just trust every sign and wonder and
miracle. Right? That talking to the dead
is necromancy. That the dead know
nothing. that communication with the
dead is communication with demons
and it's forbidden by God.
So those types of things we have to be
careful of. If you guys remember the kid
David after dentist, he was on ketamine.
Listen to his story.
>> My name is David D'vor, but you may know
me as David after dentist.
>> Is this real life?
>> You know, this surgery was not your
typical wisdom tooth uh being removed.
Just the regular laughing gas or nitrous
oxide was not going to cut it. So they
had to use ketamine.
You know ketamine is a incredibly strong
anesthetic.
>> I'm okay.
>> It has side effects.
>> I feel funny.
>> You know, double vision.
>> You have four eyes.
>> You know, deep existential experiences.
>> Is this real life? Why is this happening
to me?
>> It's okay, bud. Stay in your seat. A
>> I think he just finally just accepted it
that this was his life right now. So
there you see the effects ketamine can
have on a child. This uh David looks
like he's around the same age, possibly
younger. But the thing about ketamine is
is it is a different effect every single
time. I've been watching a lot of videos
on it the past day or two and you can
they what they're doing now uh they have
been doing this for
a couple years now.
They are actually administering ketamine
to people intervenously in a clinical
setting to help them overcome
depression, to literally get off
anti-depressants,
to feel better about themselves.
Um because
what it does is there's a lot of side
effects that come with it that are these
positive side effects. I'm not
justifying ketamine at all. I think this
is sorcery. I think this is the same as
going to a shaman and taking iwasa
or DMT. None of this stuff we should be
messing with. This is pharmarmacia
sorcery witchcraft. And this is why
hospitals have the kaducus logo because
this is all sorcery. So I'm not
justifying it at all. What I'm saying is
people saw what uh Kasein was saying and
they thought look he's repentant. They
thought for one he's saying things that
seem biblical. He he's a repentant heart
like he wants to treat his mom better
and all that stuff. And these are all
the things that come with ketamine.
That's exactly why people pay $1,000 a
pop to get IV doses of ketamine and
you're supposed to go for at least six
sessions.
And it literally changes people's lives.
People go to do Iaska, they come home
completely changed. They they are free
from all addictions. They have more
compassion for people in the world. They
all of a sudden accomplish their dreams
because they're more driven. All this
stuff comes from owasa and DMT because
of ego death. Now, is that from God? Are
these psychedelic hallucinogenic drugs
from God? Because if you're accepting a
vision from a boy who's on a psychedelic
drug, then you have to accept all the
other ones, too. Because you know how
many people are are having the same
exact identical experience on iawasa and
DMT and the same drug you took ketamine.
They're having the same experience. You
just didn't see it on this video. I've
watched these drug trips for years of my
life. I've heard people say, "I met God.
It changed my life. I I'm a better
person now. I have appreciation for
life. I I've come back to my faith." All
these things. And that's what people are
saying. is saying, "Why would this be of
the devil? Why would why would the devil
show you Jesus and heaven and your dead
loved one?" Well, for one, talking to
the dead is necromancy. That's not
biblical. So, Satan, of course, wants to
trick us into believing that you can
communicate with your dead loved ones.
This is what the Catholics do. They pray
to dead saints. They pray to dead Mary.
They pray to the dead. A lot of cultures
around the world, ancestor worship. They
pray to the dead. So why would Satan try
to convince Christians that you can pray
to and talk to the dead?
It's it's a no-brainer because he's
trying to get Christians to believe
false doctrine. He's trying to get
Christians to fall for the grand final
delusion that's coming upon the world
right now. It's already upon us. And I'm
seeing it clearer than ever when I see
100% of Christians accepting this drug
trip as a genuine vision from God.
And so, yeah, Satan, he wants to present
a Jesus. He wants to appear as Jesus, a
Jesus that embraces every culture and
there's no division. It's all love and
acceptance and unity and peace. And the
Bible says when they say peace and
safety, sudden destruction will come
upon them. A lot of Christians, we
totally misunderstand
end times prophecy, we think it's going
to be some evil ruler and he's going to
be killing Christians in the streets.
And what we don't understand is it's
going to look like peace and safety.
It's going to look like love and unity
and acceptance and tolerance and all
these things. And if you don't conform,
if you believe in thus sayeth the Lord,
the Ten Commandments, and God says this,
and there's ultimate truth, then you're
the problem. When the Pope said, "We all
serve the same God. We all serve love,
whether you're Jewish or Buddhist or
Hindu or Christian," he was promoting
the false Christ. He was promoting the
Antichrist, the false beast system. And
before Pope Francis died, he said, "All
religions point to the same God."
They're just different languages to God.
Different religions are just different
languages to God. Whether you're
Egyptian or Babylonian or Christian or
what, it's all the same. That's exactly
what we're going to be faced with in
these last days. Already we have Chris
Bledsoe, the guy who wrote a book about
how UFOs are of God and how these aliens
that he healed him of Crohn's disease
are good angelic beings simply because
they healed him. He's not using
discernment at all. He's not testing the
spirits at all. We know the Bible says
that miracle working demons are going to
deceive the entire world. And he was
healed by them and boom, that's all it
that's all it takes. I believe that
these are good angels because they
healed me. And this is what I'm seeing
more and more Christians fall for. No
discernment at all. Not testing the
spirits at all. Just eating it up,
whatever it is. So, what are we even
talking about? If this is maybe you
haven't even seen the video we're
talking about. This is Kase.
He's coming out of anesthesia like his
mom said. And listen to the type of
things he's saying here. I'm a bad kid.
>> No, you're not.
>> I miss my mom. Where's my mom?
>> I'm right here.
>> I miss my mom.
>> I'm right here. Kay.
Kay.
>> Hi, Jesus.
>> You're so beautiful.
>> He's in a green.
All right. So, notice he's not even
there. I mean, he's gone. She's like,
"Kay." He's like, "I miss my mom. I miss
my mom so much." She's like, "I'm right
here, Case." She's the one recording
him. So, first off, we see he's not
there. I mean, he's on ketamine, out of
this world. He can't even see his mom.
And he's like, "Hi, Jesus." And they
start laughing. And people are like,
"Why are they laughing? This is a
miracle from God." Like just just watch
the miracle.
The fact is is this innocent child got
pumped full of pharmaceutical sorcery
and it's not even his fault what he's
facing right now. We should be
complaining. We should be more
sympathetic that this kid got pumped
full of sorcery against his will and is
having this supernatural out-of- body
experience that now is going to affect
his entire life because especially
because
adult Christians are telling him you had
a real experience from God. I watched
the video with the mom. He doesn't even
remember this. She showed him the video.
He doesn't even remember. And that is
common on ketamine. You can have these
crazy experiences and remember them or
you can have them and not remember them,
but subconsciously
you're still affected by these things
and they still, you know, make you a
better person or whatever is what they
they sell you this by saying go to these
ketamine therapy classes or uh not
classes but sessions and it's still
going to be helpful even if you don't
remember the the scenario.
But he's saying, you know, he's saying
I'm a bad kid. you know, he's he's
already getting a dose of that empathy
that um yeah, being a being a better
person, but she's right there. He can't
he can't tell she's there. And he says,
>> "I want Dave's hot chicken.
>> I want Dave's hot chicken." So, is that
part of a vision from God, too? I mean,
what what are we going to say is like of
God? Well, that part was not of God, but
the rest of it is God. and this one
here. And you know, it's like we're got
this pick and grab stuff.
>> You're doing so good, Kase.
>> That's not my name.
>> My name is Brian.
>> Brian.
My name is Brian.
>> So, they're laughing because they know
he's coming out of this anesthesia and
this is normal to say things like,
"That's not my name. My name is Brian. I
don't know who I am. Um, notice back
here they said he's dreaming. They
wouldn't say that if he was just sober.
They would have never said dreaming.
He's dreaming, you know. So, when this
video first came out, I knew by the way
he was acting that he was on anesthesia.
I don't know how anyone watching this
video thought this kid's in his right
mind. He's sober and he's in a vision
from God. For one,
God doesn't need drugs to give you a
vision, right? And if you were in some
kind of vision from God, I don't think
there would be some of this nonsensical
stuff coming out like I I want Dave's
chicken and I don't know my name. My
name's not Bri or my name's not Kase,
it's Brian, right?
Um, and then here's this clip.
>> I know he'll save everyone.
>> So, this is where we see the false
Christ right here. I know he'll save
everyone.
Is that true? Is that what Jesus said?
he's going to come to do, right? He said
he's going to come to save everyone. Or
did he say, "I come not to bring peace,
but a sword of division."
When he comes, he said, "Few will find
it." It's it's a narrow gate, and few
will find it. Broad is the way to
destruction, but few will find the way
to life.
But here's the false Christ. The false
Christ is always here to save everyone.
It doesn't matter if you're gay or an
alcoholic or, you know, you worship
dragons in China. We're all going to be
there. We're all going to get to make it
into the kingdom of God because you're
all children of God.
And uh practicing necromancy, talking to
the dead. Now, I don't know why that
upsets people to say that. They think
I'm accusing him of being a a a
practicing necromancer. I'm not saying
that. I'm saying he was put on
pharmaceutical sorcery, pharmarmacia,
and it's opened his mind. It's opened
himself
to be deceived by demons because that's
what drugs do, right? I hope any
Christian watching believes that if you
mess with drugs, it is a gateway to the
demonic realm. I I hope that's not a a a
triggering or a shocking or a
controversial thing to say. I mean, it
seems pretty normal to believe that
partaking in alcohol, which they call
spirits, marijuana, LSD, all these
things, hallucinogenic drugs, is a
demonic gateway. I hope that's not a
controversial thing and that's accepted.
Now we have a kid that is on a
hallucinogenic drug and all of a sudden
we're accepting that this is a real
encounter with Jesus Christ that he was
really in heaven and really seeing his
dead dad and all of this was real 100%
and and not any of it a hallucination or
even a demonic deception simply because
again just like Chris Bledsoe who said
just because They healed me. They got
it. They have to be good angels. Alien
grays are good angels simply because
they healed him. In the same sense,
we're saying this has to be 100% a
vision from God because he described
Jesus as having eyes of fire. Okay, we
I'm sure he's heard that plenty of times
in church. Um, and because he's
repentant and wants to be a better
person.
That's exactly what ketamine does. So if
we believe that, then we have to accept
that iawaska, DMT, and ketamine are
gifts from God and are to be partaken by
every Christian because it gives us
encounters with Jesus and makes us more
repentant and more Christlike. Hear how
ridiculous that sounds. We have to be
rational, logical, thinking Christians
and not just keep eating up the signs
and wonders. Here's a a doctor that
administers ketamine on a regular basis
and here's what he says ketamine does.
Hey, it's Dr. Co here from ResetKetamine
in Palm Springs. Welcome. A lot of
people ask me about what it feels like
to have a ketamine infusion experience.
So, there was a doctor who was doing a
lot of research on experiences of
patients who received ketamine and his
name is Dr. Eli Culp. He described four
types of experiences that he noticed
amongst his patients. The first one is
the empathogenic experience where one
has an awareness of one's body, feelings
of comfort and relaxation, reduced ego
defenses, empathy, compassion, warmth,
feelings of love and euphoria, and where
the mind is filled with this dreamlike
effect with sometimes some very colorful
visualizations. The second one is the
outof body experience where there is a
complete separation from one's body. And
some people describe visiting
mythological realms, seeing different
spiritual beings or ghosts or deceased
relatives. It's a really interesting
experience that one can have in this
out-of- body experience. Also, there
might be dreams of the present, the
future, or the past. Or they might even
relive their birth process during this
out-of- body experience. The third stage
is the neardeath experience. And this is
a complete dissolution of one's ego
where actually someone feels like they
are actually psychologically and maybe
even physically dying. During this
experience, one might see themselves as
a single point of consciousness seeing
itself. And lastly, reliving one's own
life, going through the actions that
they've had and committed and really
doing a life review during this process.
The last and final stage is the ego
dissolving transcendental experience.
This is where there is an complete
ecstatic state of dissolution of
boundaries between the self and external
reality. Complete dissolution of one's
body and self. They might transcend
normal space and time during this
experience. And feelings of a collective
consciousness and unity with the oneness
or single consciousness of life or God
or the sacredness that is ineffable.
It's interesting because there is a wide
range of experiences and that can
actually depend upon the dose. That will
definitely depend upon the person's
mindset. it will depend upon the
environment that they are receiving
ketamine in. And so it's not necessarily
one is better than the other. Uh these
are just simply four stages of ketamine
experiences that one can have. And
regardless, it's very important to be in
an environment where you're going to be
able to experience any of these four
stages, but also feel completely safe
because it is a very vulnerable place to
be in. Please let me know what you think
about this. Leave me any questions or
comments below.
So,
[Music]
so isn't that very interesting? He
literally said that one of the effects
of ketamine is going out of your body,
seeing mystical beings or heavenly
beings or angels and things, meeting
God, meeting dead loved ones. So this is
a normal experience on ketamine. And yet
I was watching these guys. I was
watching Isaiah Salavar and he said he
was looking at a comment. He said,
"Yeah, somebody in here just said I I
work in a kid's uh hospital and this
isn't normal on on anesthesia."
So that's just intellect intellectually
dishonest. It's just dishonest to say
that this is a unique experience that
this kid is having and it has to be a
genuine 100% vision from God. It's just
it's not it's it's dishonest. It's not
even true. Not to mention
so deceptive.
And I just, you know, maybe you guys
think I sound harsh on here or
something. I'm so frustrated with the
deception.
I'm so sick of deception. I've been
deceived for many years of my life. I
finally found the truth in God's word.
And I found that even things that I was
taught in church growing up were not
true according to the Bible. That's why
I do videos like what happens really
when you die, what's the truth about
hell and and all these things because
Satan is using these Yeah. in the
rapture because Satan is using this
stuff
as a huge tool to deceive Christians.
He's trying to deceive the Christian
world. He doesn't have to deceive the
lost world. They're already lost. So,
he's trying to deceive the Christians
and he's ramping it up. The day after
this video came out, there was a kid
that nearly drowned and he had the same
experience. He saw Jesus
and you know, at least he wasn't talking
to the dead. And I'm not saying that God
can't give somebody a vision of himself.
I'm not saying that. But I'm saying this
110%
a thousand%
is not a vision from God. It's a
ketamine trip. He's talking out of his
mind. He doesn't know his own name. He
wants Dave's chicken. And he's talking
to the dead, which is forbidden by the
Bible. Why would any Christian believe
this and share this as truth and as
something to be accepted
by Christians? It's just that is how
that is how much of the discernment has
been gone from the Christian world. We
don't read our Bibles. We go to a church
that gives us a feel-good sermon. We
listen to people's prophetic dreams and
near-death experiences
and half of this junk is new age garbage
and we're just eating it up and we don't
care about truth. And this is exactly
what the Bible says is going to happen
in the last days. People will be lovers
of pleasure rather than lover lovers of
God and all this stuff. You know, things
that tickle their ears, not truth.
And this is just the the time that we're
living in.
Um, so let's see if he had an encounter
like this.
>> It's so pretty up here.
So many flowers and butterflies.
>> So he believes he's up here. He says it
it's so beautiful up here. He's looking
around and there's so many flowers and
butterflies. This is exactly what
ketamine does. We just saw the the
doctor explain this exact scenario.
Jason,
>> can you see now? Can you see?
>> I see heaven.
Heaven is so pretty.
>> So he he thinks he's in heaven right
now.
>> Dad, baby,
>> I missed you, Dad. Don't go away. Please
don't.
>> Is this normal?
Okay.
>> I love you, Jesus. I love you, God.
>> So, notice something really important
right here. The mom asks, "Is this
normal?" Because like this is really
hard to watch. You know, this kid, he's
he just lost his dad a year ago. He He
was like probably like 11, 12, 13 at the
most. He lost his dad a year ago.
What does that do to a kid? What kind of
grieving process has he actually really
went through? And now he's on ketamine.
This drug that literally is supposed to
change your entire life, make you a
better person, get rid of grief and
anguish and all these things and fix
childhood trauma. That's what this drug
does. And he's having this experience
where he's seeing his dad and he's like
just dealing with all this grief and the
mom says, "Is this normal?" And you
don't hear the response from the nurses,
but you know by the mom's response,
she's like, "Okay." that they nodded
their head and said yes. So the fact
that she said is this normal and they
said yes
should have told all of us watching that
this is not a unique experience right
>> is this normal
>> okay
>> so there's nothing unique about this but
yet people are saying this never happens
this is a this is the only time this boy
had a real vision from God and listen
what he says
>> I love you Jesus I love you God,
you're so pretty.
Did you see my mom?
>> She's so pretty.
>> She works so hard to provide for us and
I love her so much.
>> I want to be better for her. I'm so
mean.
>> You're just a teenager.
I'm so mean.
>> No, you're not.
>> I disrespect you, Mom.
>> I love you.
>> I say no to you, Mom. I'm sorry.
>> So, simply for the fact that he
is repentant. He feels bad for This is
the thing. He knows he's bad. Kids know
when they're disrespectful. Kids know
right from wrong, especially when
they've been brought up in a Christian
home. So, intellectually, internally, he
knows I'm a rebellious kid. I tell my
mom no. These are things that are not
epiphies. He knows this. But now he's on
a drug that part of its intention or its
side effects is that it brings all those
things out and it makes you recognize
them and it makes you want to do right
and be better. This is why people walk
away from these um ketamine therapies
as better people and they go for like
six sessions and they never have to go
back again. They never touch a
antid-depressant drug again. They they
uh are able to get out of bed and feel
and accomplish their dreams and do all
these things.
Again, I'm not justifying this drug at
all, but that is what they are doing
with this drug right now. So this
experience is also not unique at all.
This is normal. Just like the nurses
said when she said, "Is this normal?"
And they said, "Yes." They've seen it a
million times. People on ketamine
saying, "I'm a bad person. I want to be
a better person. I want to treat my
family better."
So this is straight from the horse's
mouth.
>> Could a single dose of ketamine make you
more caring and connected? A new study
suggests it might. That's what I'm
talking about today. I'm Dr. Tracy Marx,
a psychiatrist, and I make mental health
education videos. Today, we're diving
into some fascinating new research about
ketamine. And we're not talking about
the anti-depressant effects this time.
We're exploring how ketamine might
actually increase empathy and social
connection. This could be a gamecher for
treating conditions where lack of
empathy is a core issue, like certain
personality disorders. So certain
personality disorders like uh some
autistic people just don't have
any sympathy or empathy um what do they
call that when you there's a certain
psychological term they use for people
that don't have compassion and so
they're saying in people like that they
could administer ketamine to help with
that
and they're already practicing it. She's
saying that, you know, this study thinks
that it might it they're already using
it like it does. Um, so here's a guy
talking about his ketamine therapy
experience and what it did to him.
Ketamine, what is it like? It was wild.
I was above my body looking down,
floating. By the time that second 10
minutes was up, I was gone. I was in
another dimension again. that bubble
feeling of like just looking at the
world through a bubble. Very detached
feeling. Uh the floating above the body
like I'm looking down on the whole
therapist room. I could see him. I could
see me. I could see everything. Very
detached feeling. It really is wild how
these substances can open up a whole new
way of thinking. And the same way of
thinking I've had for 36 years of life
is just in a matter of minutes opened up
and flipped on its head. Like wow. I'd
be sitting there and then I would go for
about 7 8 minutes just gone. I would
forget who I am, where I am, what I am,
all of it. Forget that I'm human. Forget
my name is Kyle. Forget I'm in a
therapist's office. it would pop me back
into existence and I'd be like, "Oh, I'm
I'm in a therapist's office. I'm I'm
doing this." And I'd remember where I
am. And then a minute later, dive right
back into like the other realm. At the
end, I I'm I'm about to come out of it
and, you know, I just remember I start
thinking about Gemma, my dog, the one
that's on the logo of Sober Dogs. You
know, we had to put her to sleep uh you
know, a couple months prior and I was I
started crying thinking about it, but I
knew she was in a better place. It's
really like a deep spiritual internal,
you know, kind of feeling.
>> So, okay. So, here's a grown man who
said when he was on it, he was out of
his body in another world, and
he
forgot his name, forgot who he was, what
he was, and started thinking about his
dead dog and crying
and remembered she's in a better place.
So if we're going to believe every
experience from these drug trips, we
have to believe all of them. We have to
believe this guy. We have to believe the
Iawaska trip, the DMT trip.
Because the fact is what we are watching
what got 20 million views in two days
where a 100% of the Christians were
saying this is a vision from God and it
was literally a ketamine trip means that
we have to accept every drug trip as a
gift from God. A vision from God.
I mean that's that's where I think it it
stands. That might sound very black and
white but I think that's how it is. I
would forget who I am, where I am, what
I am, all of it. Forget that I'm human.
Forget my name is Kyle.
>> You're doing so good, Jason.
>> That's not my name.
>> My name is Brian.
>> Brian. My name is Brian.
>> You know, in the in the little interview
they did with the mom, she was saying,
you know, in heaven, we all have a new
name. And that's what was going on. I
looked up Brian and it meant like noble
or something.
It's like we're going to find any kind
we're going to just grasp for anything
any reason to make this some kind of
unique experience to this kid that this
has to be a vision from God. No, it has
to be. I don't care if he said his name
is Brian and he wants Dave's chicken and
he can't even see his mom and he's just
I don't care if he's on ketamine. This
is real.
You know, I'm I'm really just mind-b
blown. I'm completely at a loss for
words why we are trying so hard to make
this drug trip a real vision from God
when he's clearly not even in his right
mind. I mean, you can just tell by the
way he talks. This isn't his normal
self. He's not like, "My name's Brian."
You know, he's I want Dave's Hot
Chicken. Um,
that's why I knew for a fact, I knew
100% like this kid is on something. He's
not in his right mind. And what did he
say here? And
>> you know, I just remember I started
thinking about Gemma, my dog, the one
that's on the logo with Sober Dogs. You
know, we had to put her to sleep uh, you
know, a couple months prior and I was I
started crying thinking about it, but I
knew she was in a better place.
>> I miss you, Dad. You're so pretty.
One thing too that nobody seemed to
question is that he keeps talking about
how beautiful everything is. And I I do
believe that heaven is beautiful because
it it look you know God created the
earth to be a beautiful place and it it
is a beautiful place but it is cursed
and we see death and you see grass that
isn't green and thorns and thistles and
all that and it is a beautiful place but
he keeps talking about how beautiful
Jesus is. And I don't see anywhere in
scripture that says Jesus is beautiful.
I see.
Yes, he's uh glorious. He's radiant.
He's got eyes of fire and all that, but
nothing about beauty. It actually says
that there's no beauty in Jesus that any
man should desire him.
But when I do look at beauty in in other
parts of the Bible, I do see that
Lucifer was probably the most beautiful
angelic being in existence. So, I I
think that's another little red flag,
too, when he's always saying, "You're so
beautiful," and all this stuff. Um, like
I said, I I just think this is all just
a a hallucin hallucinogenic drug trip
that Satan is inducing on him because he
was given drugs that a child should have
never been given. And now he is he's
going to have to live with this
experience his whole life,
unfortunately.
So, here's somebody that actually saw
the dead on ketamine.
>> I saw my dead dad yesterday.
>> What? How? Ketamine therapy.
>> Ketamine is very useful for depression
and anxiety. It's also used for for
PTSD.
>> Listen, I've been dealing with this
death for a really long time.
>> Of course,
>> like grief is really difficult.
>> It's not easy.
>> Not easy. And I went into a ketamine
therapy clinic. I was like really
hesitant at first. It was a IV, so they
just put it in my arm.
>> Okay. Straight to the point.
>> And 45 minutes into the experience, I
was really failing and I ended up coming
face to face with my father.
>> Wow. and he apologized for a lot of the
things that he put me through. It was
one of the most cathartic experiences of
my life.
>> Life-changing.
>> I highly recommend ketamine therapy.
So, for anyone that's believing
that this kid had a genuine trip to
heaven,
saw his dead dad, all this stuff. Now,
we know the truth 100% that he is on
ketamine.
What about these other people that are
seeing their dead loved ones as well?
This guy just said, you know, grief is
such a hard thing and I got to see my
dad and he apologized to me and uh I
I recommend everyone do this.
Is this really what we should be
recommending? that everyone does this
mystical drug to leave their body, see a
dead person, communicate and have a
conversation with a dead person,
necromancy,
and say that this is some kind of
healing act of God.
That's where we're at today. That is
where we are at in the Christian world
where even Christians are falling for
this new age garbage where we're saying,
"Yeah, man. Just trip some acid and go
go fly out into the universe and meet
God and talk to the dead."
I never dreamed we'd be where we are
now. I never dreamed it
that Christians would be saying that
this is a gift from God that this was
man I I'm just shocked beyond belief
beyond words. One of the reasons I went
to get the ketamine therapy is because I
didn't know why I'm still on
antid-depressants. There was a moment
where I got to see my dad be around my
dad, right? And I'd never My dad died
when I was like 16 and he was really
older, man. He he was 86 when he passed
away and and I was 16. So he was older
when I was born. He was an adult, you
know, he was senior citizen, you know. I
felt like my dad never knew how much I
loved him. I felt like I just never
gotten to an age where I could tell him
that I loved him, you know, and I
literally got to have a moment or a
little bit, a couple moments with him in
a emotional state kind of. It felt like
anyway to me it felt very real to me
that I was letting him know uh how much
I loved him.
>> So, was this guy's experience real?
Will
will God allow us to communicate with
our dead dad if that's something we need
for healing?
Does it take drugs to make it happen?
There's everything is wrong with this.
Everything. Communicating with the dead
is necromancy. The dead are dead.
Anyone that you're seeing that is
deceased is a demon in disguise or
literally just a figment of your
imagination. It's a hallucination, but
it's not reality.
And the fact that it is drug induced
just makes it 100% sorcery.
This is shamanism. This is going to a a
shaman and taking a drug and walking
through this spiritual experience
that is not Christian on any level.
None.
And yet this is where we're at. This is
where we're at. We're at where the
dragon is deceiving the entire world,
including Christians. I could see all
the world buying into this junk. I could
see that. Not Christians. Why? Wake up.
This is crazy.
The last time I did a ketamine
treatment, I died. Not literally died,
but sometimes on high enough doses of
the medicine, people have a death
experience. And I went out into the
void. I was there all alone. And I was
like, man, I made it through everything
that I've been through. And I took the
ketamine and I died. Oh man, I'd give
anything to get it back. It made me
appreciate my life and what we've
accomplished and my family so much. And
when I really truly thought I'd give
anything to get it back.
I went back down into my body and it
made me appreciate my life and
everything that I had so much more.
>> It's got to be from God, man. Made him
made him repentant. Made him want to be
a better person. Made him appreciate
life. Has to be from God 100%.
Ketamine,
the drug from Jesus.
You might be wondering, why am I crying
during my ketamine sessions? You might
be crying because ketamine seems to
dissolve the layer between the conscious
and the unconscious mind. So, if there's
a lot of tears or sadness that's quote
underneath of the hood, it might just
bubble up to the surface. So having
those emotions of sadness, releasing the
tears may be really important. It's
actually a form of release in a way. And
it might be tears from joy. It might be
tears from sadness. It might be
different emotions that have not been
processed in the past. And so during the
ketamine therapy, if that comes up, that
can be pretty normal for some patients,
especially if they've been holding
various emotions down.
>> So this is what I think happened. You
know, I just think that this kid, he
just lost his dad a year ago. He he
hasn't grieved properly. I mean, he's a
kid for one. It's only been a year, and
now he's on ketamine, and all this
stuff's just coming out. And so, he had
and he he lost his dad, too. Um I mean,
his his grandpa.
So, he saw his grandpa in the vision as
well. The the hallucination he said, um
papa and his dad. And so, like I said, I
don't agree with this medicine. I think
it's a hallucinogenic
drug that is literally pharmacia sorcery
and a gateway to the demonic realm to
lead people into deception about
religion and spirituality and all that
stuff. Because anyone who's messing with
these drugs always has a wrong view, a
non-biblical view on God, who Jesus is,
what happens when you die, religion, all
that. Most of the time it's
we have this um infinite energy in us
that when you die, it goes on through
the universe, man. And it just keeps on
going. And you can go out there and meet
God and she's beautiful, bro. and Mother
Earth and Gaia and all this stuff,
right? That's what drugs gets you. But
Satan has a flavor for everyone. So, if
you're an 11-year-old boy who been
brought up in church your whole life and
he wants to deceive your family and 20
million people in two days, he's going
to give you a little vision of heaven
and your dad and all these beautiful
sounding things that sound biblical. And
he's going to make you feel repentant.
And that's where people that's where
people have such a hard time believing.
They're like, "Why would this be
demonic? He was repentant." Satan
doesn't care how good of a person you
are. He doesn't. New age people are some
of the kindest, most loving people you
will ever meet. The most self-giving,
self-sacrificial people you will ever,
ever meet. They are not Christian in the
least. Or in the Yeah. In the least. And
they even believe in Jesus. They even
believe in Jesus. Which is why James
says even the demons believe and
tremble. But it takes more than just
belief. Takes more than just believing
in Jesus to be saved and to be a
Christian.
This guy had a lot of great nuggets.
>> Ketamine seems to induce these mystical
experiences. Sometimes it might be
feeling connected with universe, with
God, angels, and it can be quite
otherworldly during the ketamine
infusion experience. And what's really
powerful about that is sometimes when we
connect with a higher part of us,
something beyond what it means to be
just a normal human being, but kind of
tapping into that metaphysical other
dimensional world. Whether it's true or
not, it can be quite profound during the
ketamine infusion journey.
Yeah. So, he's right there on it talking
about um being in this other realm and
stuff. Now, this was a long video. I'm
not going to play the whole thing, but
the ve the very beginning she gets into
ketamine and talking to the dead and
stuff. This whole video is called um
dead relative scene while on ketamine.
Is there a link between psychedelics?
That's what the name of the video is.
Um they they tell me I felt myself
floating
and then they look really confused and
then I ask them I'm like well um is
there something more? And then they tell
me yes um my body I know my body is in
the chair and I'm holding on to the the
side of the recliner but I know my I'm
separate from my body so I guess it's
their consciousness.
>> And I tell them yes that's exactly
that's exactly correct. They go, "So
that was your psychedelic trip." Um,
then they, you know, they tell they tell
me these like other worldly things like
I saw relatives that were deceased. I
saw
um ancestors, they saw where they went
on vacation maybe the year before with
somebody that was no longer with them.
Um, what else?
They were flying. It's just different
stories. So, kind of um if somebody was
making up fairy tales, I guess it's kind
of sounds like that, but I I know from
from having to experience the we do an
experiential treatment as part of our
job. Our doctor believes that we need to
be in our patients shoes to understand
to explain to them to keep that sentence
setting sacred for them.
So I just wanted to show that that this
is a very very common thing that happens
on ketamine that you heard it from the
doctor. You heard it from different
people saying I saw my dad. I mean these
different people, not just this kid,
multiple people who went to have
um a legal
guided
shamanistic
hallucination experience
saw their dead loved ones. I mean, this
is what this is a legal thing now.
Therapy, ketamine therapy. You can go
and for just under a thousand dollars a
pop, you can have your ketamine through
an IV and go have all these mystical
experiences just like this is this is
America's version of going in a hut
somewhere and drinking iawasa and puking
and pooping everywhere and having this
experience. This is America's cleancut,
white lab coat,
you know, white walls, and it's it's
acceptable, right? Because it's doctor's
orders. It's not even considered a drug.
Actually, the guy who said he remembered
his dead dog, the name of his channel is
Sober Dogs. And at the end, he said some
some of you might be saying, "Oh, you
relapsed." He said, "No." He said being
on this is a a a doctor
supervised and uh he said this is a
medical therapeutic treatment. This was
not a drug. Yet I beg to differ. This
was a drug trip. A hallucin
hallucinogenic
drug trip just like taking DMT or
Iawasa. No difference at all. Now this
is the last clip I got for you guys. I
could have went two hours on this. I
just I don't want to use I don't want to
go on for too long, but I don't want to
not give enough evidence as well. But
this guy basically said that 5 years ago
he lost his faith, but after he did
ketamine, he came back to God because he
went to heaven on ketamine. Um, this guy
was going through something called
agorophobia
where he's terrified to even get out of
his bed and had to pee in a little cup
and his wife would pour it out for him
and stuff like he was in a very bad
condition. And I don't have the answers.
I don't know how you deal with people
that are going through this. I don't
know what the cure is, but ketamine
fixed him. Now he can get up and go on
hikes and all this stuff. And again, I'm
not justifying this. I'm not promoting
it in any kind of way,
but
the side effects of these positive
things and coming back to faith in God
and all this stuff, we can't just say
it's of God because it made you a better
person and made you closer to God. We
can't fall for that. That is the biggest
trick, man. Biggest deception. Listen to
this.
>> Uh, in my case, it was an IV drip
treatment. And when it's first coming on
and your eyes are closed, and in my
case, I was just listen to the music. My
friend was in the room with me the
entire time for every treatment. And
you're just in the best way possible,
you just completely leave your body. I
felt myself just completely free float,
leave my body, and it was absolutely
remarkable. I I saw these visions. I was
in a brand new place. like I was in an
actual physical place. It was this like
long corridor for lack of a better term.
It was like this long hallway and there
were all these beautiful pillars and it
just felt so welcoming and I felt like I
was home honestly. Like I remember
telling my friend that even in the
middle of the treatment I'm like cuz you
know you could still talk even though
you're in this weird it's hard to
explain that part cuz you're in this
weird other realm but at the same time I
could still kind of talk to my friend.
So, I'm sure some of the stuff I was
saying made no sense to him, but it was
like this long hallway with these
beautiful just these columns on either
side and the colors were just gorgeous
and I felt so at one and at peace with
everything. I felt at peace with my life
and at peace with the world like not
even at peace with my life. Let me
actually correct myself because I had no
concept of life or anything like that. I
was just so at peace. I wasn't worried
about anything. I wasn't worried about
anxiety. I wasn't worried about money. I
wasn't worried about bills. I wasn't
worried about anything. I was in this
beautiful, beautiful place. And oh my
god, I I wish everybody could experience
that part of it. But it did. It felt
like a warm hug from the universe or
warm hug from God or warm hug from Jesus
or whatever you want to call that. It
was a beautiful, beautiful experience.
It is one of the most relaxing
out of body positive experiences you
could ever ever have. And it got me from
one dramatic point of being bedridden,
peeing in a urinal, being embarrassed,
not showering, none of this stuff, none
of that hygiene or taking care of
myself, none of it to now. I just went
for a hike yesterday
and the ketamine is what started all of
it. Hey, if you have any questions about
the religious aspect of it, the fact
that I know for a fact where I was, like
there's no nobody, not a soul on this
planet can convince me I wasn't there. I
know what I saw. And what I saw was
represented in that picture I showed
you. Hands down. There's not a question.
No way. Not a question in my life.
That was God showing me that I was going
to be okay. And unfortunately, it took
me still quite a few years to get back
to that and get back to God and get back
to Jesus. But I'm so glad that I did
because it's been completely
life-changing. And since then, uh, since
I refound my faith a couple of months
ago, I just lean heavily into that and
I'm healing. I'm healing in so many
beautiful, beautiful ways. And I just
hope that you all can heal. Whatever
that healing looks like for you, I'm not
trying to convert anybody to any
particular denomination or anything like
that. That's not what this is about.
Whatever that healing looks for you, I
pray that you find it. But ketamine
infusion was definitely the right step
for me.
>> I just want you to pay attention to
what's in his room. It's 4:20 somewhere.
If you don't know what that means, it
means it's time to smoke weed somewhere.
He's got a picture of Chichin Chong back
there. You know, I'm not trying to to
judge the guy, but he's he's saying he's
a a Christian. I'm a, you know, it took
me a while to get there, but I'm back to
my faith in Jesus because of ketamine
and you can have it, too. Just take some
ketamine and you can see Jesus face to
face. Take some drugs. You can feel the
peace that I felt. You can see your dead
loved ones.
You can make all the grief go away.
Man, this is where we're at, guys.
I don't have much more to say. I've
pretty much said everything I need to. I
just pray. I've been praying for days
now that something I shared in the first
video or in the memes that I made, I
made graphics. I wrote posts because
this was so shocking to me that people
were accepting this without question
that I just had to try and make people
think. Like, come on. Don't don't you
realize that he is speaking out of his
mind? Don't you realize that um he said
that that Jesus is coming to save
everyone? Like come on. Is any of this
not a red flag to you? Like come on.
Like I it's hard not to be frustrated. I
feel like just shaking the Christian
world. Like wake up. We are in the time
where the the 10 virgins the 10 virgins
with oil which is the Holy Spirit are
asleep. Virgins represent Christians.
The oil represents the Holy Spirit. All
10 of them fell asleep in the parable.
Then they all woke up, but only five had
enough oil or Holy Spirit in their lamps
to make it to the wedding. It's time to
wake up. We can't be sleeping. we which
is a spiritual sleep. We can't be
falling asleep on all the deception
that's about to come upon the face of
the world like we've never experienced
before. Literally Satan appearing as
Christ performing signs and wonders,
miracle working demons are going forth
to the kings of the earth to unite the
whole world together in a battle against
Christ. That's where we're at in
prophecy. If this was a blessing, if it
opened up your eyes, if you know
somebody that needs to see this, please
click a thumbs up. It helps this video
get out into their algorithm. If you're
new, click subscribe so you don't miss
another video like this. And please
share this with your family and friends.
They need to see the truth so they will
not be deceived in these last days. I
love you guys. We cannot do this without
you. If you want to support this
ministry, please do so by going to
cantruth.org. We got some different ways
to give on there. Cash App, Vinmo
Moselle, and PayPal. If you guys like
t-shirts, we got some merchandise in our
store. And we will see you guys next
time on Candid Truth.